even my parents they taught us terrible
stories I remember one time me and my
brothers we were in Spain we were so
young we were playing pool and there
were these guys that were getting a bit
too friendly with us they were like
grown men and they invited both my
brothers and me I think back to their
house to see their trophies but I was
uncomfortable I'm obviously the youngest
and I I'd run back to mum and dad and
then mum and dad came to get us or
whatever anyway in the car just remember
my mom and dad was so angry that we even
told us what they would have done to us
and I was like and then I remember my
dad would be like you're being too
graphic and then I was like no she needs
to hear it they all need to hear it